hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Blair which I'm
still mad I'm I'm I'm still grumbled
because he was [ __ ] what happened
but I will let it slide for now I've got
a key so what do I do with the key what
do i do come on show me huh where's this
wish I've heard so much of axe I haven't
heard anything about the witch where's
this witch I think I've heard something
about last session with patient he is
leaving Burkittsville in his own words
he feel he's able to move on I'm glad
about this let's glad about the how
he'll be enlisting in the military
service as his father a colonel
convinced him to join worried about what
effect this environment will have on a
sensitive psyche the stress and trauma
of active duty might completely displace
his childhood trauma in the woods the
same trauma that he already seems to
have forgotten however I am afraid the
woods will never leave him no matter
what occurs it will remain beneath the
formative experience that made him who
he is today everybody outside oh the boy
I've seen right through your clever ruse
and if you think this house scares me it
certainly does not oh yeah I knew I got
that key for some reason alright okay
maybe that's it maybe this house scares
me a little bit hello
good question how did I end up back here
won't budge you want to run that by me
again
chief oh god oh god I'm looking at a
video sorry I decided to watch a whole
movie at that one juncture you was
different the light just made it Angry
okay so what not that I could do about
the oh oh okay
what excuse me okay yeah maybe this
maybe this house can't scare me a little
bit but not that much
only a tiny bit teensy tiny itty bitty
bit not a lot definitely not a lot
oh hey is this battery okay what do I
need that for definitely doesn't go to
my either my flashlight or my camera Oh
interesting
oh I'll be back I gotta explore the rest
of the house uh I know right whoa okay
all right well that's that's weird
I like the fluids oh hey this is uh this
is a bullet-sized hole wait that sounds
weird hey here we go what do we have
here
[Music]
[Applause]
the ruined that that is some nice
decoration one would not use it you're
making this easy on me you're making
this easy you're making this easy on me
your Meghan is just too easy on me just
too goddamn easy you think that you're
being clever huh oh oh
that's already open all right then fine
fine I was gonna do that myself and now
I know what you want me to do here Peter
I don't think as Peter I got a funcle'
this feeling that I ain't Peter oh well
that looks warm and inviting starting
with the jump scares I get you boo I get
you I see what you're talking about
I'll pick it up when you put
I am it alright okay sure hey the
naughty chair alright it gives you power
it gives you a chance to hold a life in
your palm you touch the twigs and you
run your fingers through their bones you
press them down you break their spine
she watches you once you pick them up
she won't let you put them down and a
whispers becomes sweeter every time you
clench your fist okay nice poem man need
some more rhyming but you know not bad
not too shabby lovely okay I guess I
can't open that one I didn't want to
anyway okay goodbye
what can be done weird this is cool
effect though I like I like a lot of
what this game done okay
never mind I hate I hate what this game
does I hate it I don't like what this
game does this game to us some horrible
things just morrible horrible things
that's done is done oh it's nice I would
never dream of it I would never dream of
it alright okay
is that you miss Blair miss wish mrs.
which mrs. which I love your invention
no happy ending you are for her says you
nerd happy happy
yeah you can't stop me from being happy
happiness is all in the mind
hello hello boo you are for her mmm who
say that no happy in it yeah oh you of
you I'm reading that okay I'm sorry
it's just too much I can't take it
anymore
I won't let you drag me down with you
well you know okay
I don't know where it says I don't love
you anymore
oh it says right there on the wall there
well I don't love you anymore
well you know maybe I'm saying that to
my demons
maybe I'm saying demons I don't love you
anymore I love myself because I do all
right
good great good great good good
slow hello he's just sick of it
he's not even bother but of course over
huh
[Music]
oh hello
I didn't mean to Wow my hands are just
messed up huh man my hands are messed up
man I get it man I get it turn on the
lights the headlights turn them on I
know I call I am currently calling it I
have called it and I am calling it now
I'm calling it I'm calling all the
goodness anyway I'm calling this Oh
Sheriff hi hey how are you doing
I'm willing to bet if I click that I'm
gonna kill him
yes knew that knew that was happening
alright well that was good
let you carefully well we said don't
look well I'm looking what are we doing
baby baby are you a good man Alice oh
you know pretty good
I try don't look oh how do you imagine
your future oh you know probably yeah
look you look you dead
uh well follow the path don't look I
really want to look now god I really
want to look light wakes and oh I really
want to look oh there's no other way
I'll have to sneak past dead somehow
you mean this light Oh peekaboo hey wait
a minute that looks like Carter all
right all right don't look okay I'm not
looking I would never dream of looking I
wouldn't dream of looking good thing
they told me a million times all right
making this a little difficult on you
guys I guess they're gone now I can look
be a man for once why oh well
can't really do that no can I there
you're okay all right
don't mind me don't look up I wasn't
planning on it what am I supposed to do
here oh I see I see let me just close
this door there okay all right good good
great
where am I going okay well maybe I
should take a nap
we're all like it hello like Oh turns
out I don't like it I wasn't gonna buff
him I wasn't planning going that way
anyways just a joke I was trying to
prank you but you got me before I was
able to prank you good so uh you know
that's your loss for not getting my
hilarious pranks um up or down up me
down here I like up beat up robbery in
progress see being in store near
Burkittsville Road those kids again yeah
someone relay Oh someone saw me and got
scared
yeah cool good what's uh what's up here
what's going on hey how you doing hey
what's what's the dealio hey
I got here well I guess this is what I
have to go on now you know there was a
downstairs that I didn't get a chance to
go to yeah you better run you better run
man you better run
am I the monster now oh hi hi scary but
it wasn't know what that was about
oh hey what's up oh how are you doing
[Music]
all right go good duck I've never found
the hole standing looking at a corner
thing scary I've just always thought it
was kind of funny
all right oh okay all right good good
time
Thanks okay
[Applause]
maybe who's asking
I know who you well I don't know you
incoming from Jessie the local teenager
allegedly involved in a convenience
store library was shot by a police
officer arriving at the scene the
suspect was transported to a nearby
hospital in critical condition
local authorities confirmed that the
suspect was alright
fascinating you know this house seems
kind of big oh okay it's a blame for
that okay it's not where it all started
is it like don't know I don't know is it
I don't know how would I know
nice Cheers I don't like I don't like
good I've seen this run before
yeah yeah I've seen it many times now
okay well that's nice okay how about
that stick dangling I guess there's
nothing oh here comes our handsome lad
hey Victor you shot her pretty face off
in basic training
yeah what kind of girl is what H he's
what what
wait what what what what but you didn't
finish what you were talking about oh hi
yeah are you doing you okay there buddy
hey buddy what are you alright oh oh hey
there you are sir
sir yes sir free butcher Oh Oh sir sir
Sir
what what what sir sir sir okay that's
weird oh oh that's weird
uh I am there god this is so weird this
like surreal sequence has gone on so
much longer than I ever could have
imagined all right oh god you suck oh hi
[Applause]
oh okay all right okay you playing with
me now
oh you playing with me now and they
still investigative report Oh report
operative of Jackson says unaccomplished
summary due to errors made during
reconnaissance the enemy forces were
aware of the position of our troops I
see incompetent hi I didn't notice you
popping up out of the water like that so
you can forgive me for not seeing you
there okay goodbye
Wow great amateur that's fun which
allowed them to conduct a surprise
attack combatants killed in action now
Allen Pomerance the Elwood Brosco
Hayward Oliver Marley Sylvester boys
Keith's course I still keep trying to
call for bullet I do I can't help it all
right hi how you doing hey what's going
on sorry I didn't mean is she all right
yeah but hey you know it's all good
don't worry about it I'm here to help
to do what exactly I didn't know what I
was doing what did I just do I just
released a floodgate I don't know what
that did I'm not sure what that did and
I don't think it resulted in anyone's
death so I don't think you can blame me
for that one I think you can blame me
for that one at all anyway good talk
good talk guys good talk glad everyone's
conversing with me so strong Hey
all right let me destroy this hey wait
what's wrong with this one it's not
wrong all right oh hey buddy Hey
how you doing there good see ya sorry
about this whole ordeal anyway we'll let
bygones be bygones huh I didn't know
that that thing was gonna do that to you
so not my fault not my fault oh hey it's
this place I was wondering if I was ever
gonna get here I was wondering if I was
ever gonna see this I saw in the last
video I saw you oh you know what I would
do I would just put her back
[Music]
and instantly better all better baby all
better baby
all better all better baby oh all better
baby why can't I go no door handle ah
now it's open I see okay now I get it
oh I hope it's from Jess he's here your
shadow um well I can't see my shadow so
you where I'll try about what how are
you doing how are you doing I'm so aware
you look you dead I know I know this is
don't look up I wouldn't dream of it
he's easy go easy Pazuzu afraid not
really yeah what's up someone say my
name I would say I would like to get out
of this house now I've been in this
house for a long time
I've been wandering around the same
areas for a long time yeah what's up can
I go through here all through here I see
[Music]
all right I don't know it's so funny you
could let me in on the joke I would like
to laugh I like laughing laughing is
good good for the lungs good for me for
all this really don't look up well you
know I might careful
whatever whoever's giving me these
message sure is nice they really are
nice who oh I see well I think I see
okay just canoodling on by I don't mind
me yeah
all right Alan Paul divorced
Keith forced yeah okay Sylvester boys
Sylvester boys last night Rosco hey
uh-huh you're both dead because of me
well I mean maybe not probably not
anyway it doesn't seem to be your fault
to be perfectly honest but I can see how
you would blame yourself god damn it
huh I still have no idea what the lore
of the Blair Witch actually is but I
hope I meet her someday I really hope I
do boy howdy I just love that selfish
well you know sometimes you got to be a
little selfish in life murderer
well you know sometimes you gotta be a
little murdery in life oh I know that
sound effect I've used it before I'm
something I don't know what that's
supposed to be but I do not like this
picture
let's pictures uncomfy the pictures real
uncomfy
that's an uncommon good great glad I did
that
can I get the hell out of this house now
thanks thank you
all right can I get out of here
once you're done yelling at me you know
you could just die let me get out of
that oh hi
I don't know what I saw you could let me
get out of the house and it well I'm
going up now I go up I'm up I'm up I'm
up I'm up
oh [ __ ] no no get a hold of yourself
I don't know about always Oh gross but I
love it oh god my carpet my carpet who
do you think you are Wade's house fine
whatever
I guess I'll get that dry-cleaned oh oh
I guess - Wow who are you Ellis a good
question yeah I don't really know
anymore the big reveal
follow the path careful flop it careful
bump it Thanks whoo you look you're dead
all right
Oh
there you are all the path but I don't
see the path anymore I think I need to
go the way that it's walking through I
just can't run into it is a busy
[Music]
okay all right I thought whoa oh hi bud
how you doing buck arena careful yeah
careful captain I see your titties do
what dude do what I got another message
you can't look at yourself in the mirror
anymore can you
oh good but apparently not hello Oh
another tape good the corner so are they
finally explaining why you have to look
in the corner I'm going in the Carter
I'm in the corner I'm not looking but I
want to look I want to look real bad
I shouldn't have looked okay I should
okay all right I think I get it now I
get it
oh nice corner I'm a good boy
I'm a good boy looking at the good no no
no no no no no no no no oh I don't like
that heart what's over there what's
going on
oh you don't show me ah you don't show
me the witch you ain't gonna show me the
woods I gotta fight the corner boss
that's like boxing but more corner well
it's my favorite part of corner corner
yeah you can't make me look there's no
way I would look I like this corner no
no no no my pretty face is for my wife
only my wife nope no no no no oh God
[Laughter]
just trying to survive can I look now
peekaboo okay okay so I stood in the
corner like a good boy
what now what again
don't like this picture picture very
problematic uh what also what's with my
hands my hands are getting dirty and
gray and weird and almost like Carson's
carving Corvin whoa whoa whoa whoa okay
sure oh that's normal
okay
okay oh hi I saw you I saw you in the
corner there what you doing what soon
okay nevermind there we go alright oh
yeah you better run you better run okay
oh hi don't look T better not look look
I'm very scary weird weird oh I see
Wow
oh well that's that wasn't me
you can't pin that on me I didn't do
that
all right I guess I can't look away all
right well okay all right
still here huh still right here
Oh eyeballs Oh
um I'm sorry what happened I'm sorry
what happened you all right okay well no
need to get upset
yeah yeah yeah cuz I like the kaboom he
powers the kaboom is pretty good oh yeah
now this is what I was talking about my
entire life you've come home yeah come
on oh yeah kid gone yeah decrepid oh
well uh you're dead shouldn't look
shouldn't look that's hard to look at oh
hey boo boo you're gone I'm guessing
that what I'm doing right now ain't good
but you know it is what it is you know
okay
just happened what was that you know I
would love to know that but I've been
wandering around the same house for an
hour and I have no idea when it's gonna
end the basement
oh yeah I'm finally here oh yeah you're
right I am Peter Peter
Peter where are you Peter Peter Peter
Gators
I don't know man I don't know I don't
even know if he exists I think it's just
me to be perfectly honest he's not here
I gotta open this lock but I gots to
find it where are you mother [ __ ]
watch your language I'm gonna kill you
with my bare hands and after what you've
done I'm going to enjoy it
[Music]
oh how convenient I probably should have
seen that before
all right then fine have it your way
nerd huh I'm coming for you with my
strangle in hands get my grabbers right
I've been breaking lots of stick bundles
lately and you're gonna snap like a twig
there's a perfect size hole for bullet
to crawl through but oh well I can't see
anything oh there we go
oh it's a cutscene it is
[Laughter]
[Music]
no no no no please please please please
I'm not gonna hurt you please please
please please please
sorry
this is what you take your [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ]
it's finally shut up all those people a
shield I'll rip your [ __ ] heart
[Music]
Oh
bullet bullet Wow
Ellis gave into his rage in despair the
cycle continues Carver was born again
despite his injuries bullet survivors
later found wandering outside of
Shannon's house Jess was determined to
patch things up with else but he ignored
her efforts spending more and more time
in the woods Peters fate remains unknown
with no clue to its whereabouts sheriff
landings body was never recovered from
the bucketful what Thom McCann's body
was found months later in the tapi East
Creek sawmill so rotten it was nearly
beyond identification what wait wait
wait
hang on I got I got to see something
here
oh I know what it was it was these
moment are you kidding me that's it was
the moments to commit the murders god
damn you so hard
god damn you so that was it that's what
determines the ending that you get that
soap and in this freaking long sequence
it's a this is not a short segment are
you kidding me oh are you joking me are
you first you take bullet away from me
and oh and then you decide well guess
what here comes the persistent [ __ ]
again ready to win the persistent
[ __ ] award i'ma play through his
whole [ __ ] again so that you can't
freak me over like you just did game oh
my god oh I am more than a little
grumbled at the moment guys I am more
than a little girl unfold or I'll be
back
[Music]
wait so okay so nothing nothing was
different all that extra effort was for
nothing then what do you do to get
something better
I'm so confused you do I don't know how
to change the outcome but I'm sure
there's a way what I'm worried is that
it's part of this pre-release version
only as this one ending in it because I
don't know what else I could have done
it's obvious that my actions affected
other things in the game I just don't
know what I could've done because I
thought it was my choices at that end
sequence that did it but it seemed to be
locked into a linear path no matter what
and I'm not a hundred percent sure what
that's all about there's one last thing
I want to try that I could try to
understand but I'm not a hundred percent
sure because from here it seems like
this is the it seems like this is the
big change it seems like this is it
because this seems like when he gets
consumed by rage but there's no other
thing to do there's no other thing to do
I can't just wait this out I can't even
access my inventory anymore it's all
just gone at this point so
what did I just do so anyway
unfortunately that's the end I really
like this I really like this and I'm
just like so confused and I can't even
look up a guide because of the pre
Lily's version no one else has this game
yet I don't know what I've been wrong I
don't know but at least bullet is alive
that much we can all be happy about
because I saved bullet
I saved bullet I did save bullet and
that we can all be happy with I think
what the thing is like the other endings
aren't available now because there was
no other thing that I could possibly do
so with that being said I will let this
lie for now and if there's something
else in this game I won't be able to do
it until I get back from Korea but for
now thank you everybody so much for
watching
this was really cool there's a lot of
really cool ideas to explore I love the
way it changed the world it was a little
bit too long on that last sequence but
I'll let it I'll let that slide in yeah
I think I'm just biased because I had to
go through it again just to see if there
was anything I could do differently but
apparently there was not thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought down to comes
below and if you have an idea of what I
did wrong let me know in the comments as
well oh and if you want to see more
horror games that I've played in the
past
I'll put quite a few down in the
description as well from alien isolation
to other long-form - all the way back to
slender the arrival which is kind of in
a similar vein to this game but all of
those wonderful long horror games that
I've played I'll put a few in the
description below so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]